donc avant de vous lancer dans un régime
moi je vous propose quand même de faire
un petit un petit calcul c'est tout
simplement de savoir quel est votre
l'indicé de masse corporelle et
connaissant ni m6
non pourquoi dix jours dans mon calcul à
miam ses visées par la racine carrée de
c'était super baladerait cran car ça
mais non pas du tout c'est pas le
prouver je mets deux mondes à carreaux à
géraldine maillet quand même la
spécialiste mannequin elle a fait
attention
c'est là le poids divisé par la taille
au carré
voilà prenez donc d'accord c'est que
c'est comme moi on sait le poids alors
il faut expliquer ses 80 kg par exemple
/ 1,72 si vous faites un mètre 72 entend
une fois par 1,72 je voudrais connaître
l'état 83 kg autonome et humain sur
combien benjamin m 92 77 attend plus
moche pas marché avec 4 je te fais ça
tout de suite mon poulet mais alors 83
kg et du galaxy 77 au carré ouais je
pense qu'israël essaie de s'accrocher
mais attention c'est du mur arrière
hamza ben on attendait les mc cain
quelques de base mais si on est très
musclé par exemple oui non mes chansons
quel final texte annonce pour nom c'est
ça on peut voir des mecs comme ça
important alors que en fait réellement
on n'a pas beaucoup de grâce à
l'application c'est en fait normalement
voilà doit être entre 20 et 25 pour un
garçon comme toi et qu'en tu es au
dessus de 25 on considère que tu es en
surpoids mais on revient un peu sur
cette mesure d'âge est de faire du bien
là si le gars est un peu musclé et c'est
bon c'est pas la même chose on regarde
son rapport aussi
bastien mais je donc dans le musc était
plus lourd que la grèce c'est pour ça
que je sais c'est pas une mesure
extrêmement fiable on mesure le tour de
taille abdominaux donc il faut ça allait
bien on fait et l'imc ouais ouais mais
benjamin chez un copain donc ça va là on
est d'accord on est d'accord docteur
cohen on et d'actes d'accord que dans un
mas castaldi est parfait là ils étaient
encore quatre cinq lots 4 5 kilos mais
non c'est pas ça le problème c'est
l'obsession se faire qu'à un moment
donné tu atteins ton poids tu veux
toujours aller un peu plus loin là c'est
l'erreur c'est là où tu va plonger tu
vas tomber exactement là où justement
gelé revenir sur les régimes parce que
ça devient une obsession tout le monde
parle de régime vous avez déjà fait des
régimes je viens de voir car au regard
des turbines qui a levé les yeux au ciel
en mode testé pour ça c'est un
métabolisme des graphiques escrimeuse de
l'oni enfin j'ai vraiment non j'ai envie
d'utiliser un très gros mot mais je vais
vous avez une étoile direct à taxer
d'être trop minces ou des traumas
typique et je vous jure que c'est vrai
on peut être très complexe et surtout à
l'adolescence pouvoir grossir
ilse de se trouver les vrais à la raison
c'est vrai de toute façon toutes les
morphologies peuvent peuvent créer des
complexes a effectivement il ya des
jeunes femmes qui se trouvent trop
mecque et qui font d'ailleurs des régime
grossissant s'exilait et d'ailleurs les
gens qui sont maigres ils se plaignent
de ça qu'on s'occupe jamais 2 et cantons
et des vidéos sur eux ils disent oui
c'est super vous avez pensé à moi bah
oui on ne sait vrai donc si que je peux
te faire grossir quand tu veux mais moi
j'aime ça n'allait pas c'est quoi le
toit pour cause c'est à roussir que j'ai
fait pendant des années surtout quand
j'étais dans l'adolescence c'est qu'ils
ont mangé veut la pâte à crêpes cru donc
farine sucre et je mangeais salle
accueillait les trucs qui faisait que je
me rends très maire de gond